Ebola has killed more than 2,000 people
in the east of the Democratic Republic
of Congo over the last year the UN
secretary-general Antonio Guterres flew
to the epicenter of the outbreak
the town of Beni to express solidarity
we need to put the same effort into the
fight against Ebola as we have with
dealing with insecurity in all affected
regions by mobilizing all means inside
the country and with the international
community in order to eradicate this
outbreak since the first cases were
identified a year ago the government
struggled to contain it
many people don't trust the government
or its health workers some of the
treatment centers have been attacked by
militia see a problem the control of
Ebola outbreak is taking too much time
this outbreak is serious this is why we
need the government to do more but the
response has been helped by an effective
vaccine secretary-general met people
who've recovered from the virus
treatments are more effective than
before chances of survival are higher
kuvira
Alan a lost most of her family before
she recovered her mother was the first
to die after my mom's burial I also
became terribly ill with a high fever
then they started giving me medicine
when I got better I was welcomed back by
my other relatives in spite of
international support and the improving
treatment new cases keep emerging
further and further from where the
outbreak began Guterres has promised
more support is the world's second worst
Ebola outbreak people are waiting to see
how many more months or years it will
take to bring it under control
Malcolm Webb al-jazeera Nairobi Kenya